we have a voicemail number which you can
call
really any time of day and there's
people who call it at times that i tend
to be asleep and that's fine and we love
it
that number is 219 to david p recently
on the bonus show
there were some comments made by
producer pat
which many in our audience were
titillated by
including about pat's jujitsu
proficiency
and pat's height and weight and one of
the people that was very much
taken by it was the egg man who had the
following to say
hi dave i recently learned that pat is
six foot two
202 pounds and a jujitsu expert
damn dave did you hire him as a producer
or your bodyguard
fellow brother right exactly and i think
that you know in in uh
in executive security a really great
thing
is when you can't tell who is actually
security is that a staffer
is that a policy person uh or or is that
security so yes
eggman clearly on to something and of
course uh pat's training
has all been uh to develop a very
particular set of skills that will be
useful not intellectually but also
physically and to keep everybody very
very safe
on the bonus show today i don't know how
many people in the audience saw
this crazy jerry falwell jr
picture with his pants unbuttoned a very
strange thing
i really don't care about jerry falwell
jr in any way
other than the fact that he is or was a
higher up
at liberty university the son of one of
the most
vile now the late jerry falwell senior
one of the most vile
sort of evangelical hard right lunatics
who
blamed 911 on gay people and
women having abortions i mean these are
really vile people and then now jerry
falwell
in the heat of some real problems and we
will talk about that
also in georgia a teenager took
pictures of crowding in the hallways at
school
on the first day back and was suspended
for it
okay she pointed out
how badly things are being managed in
the school
she pointed out that she's not safe and
she was suspended if you can imagine
this says exploded she was interviewed
and we're going to talk about
how she is now actually receiving
threats and should it surprise us
if dr fauci's daughters are receiving
threats
obviously a kid who exposes the lack of
safety measures
in georgia schools given what's going on
in georgia given governor kemp's
uh uh lack of of of adherence to the
facts and empiricism
i don't think we should be surprised
that she is now receiving threats
and in the meantime amazon which is a
company that is doing very well during
the pandemic because people want to
have things delivered to their homes
amazon is reportedly discussing using
former jcpenney and seer stores both
uh big box chains that have suffered
greatly recently thanks to the online
uh boom amazon's looking at using
jcpenney and see your stores as
fulfillment centers
which there's like a sort of coming full
circle aspect to what we're seeing
in the business world lately amazon now
opening physical bookstores if you can
imagine
after destroying so many local
bookstores so all of those stories and
more we will discuss on today's bonus
show
two ways to get instant access to the
bonus show become a member
at joinpacman.com or become a patron
at patreon.com davidpakmanshow
also you can continue to follow my
training for the chess.com pogchamps 2
tournament
with my live streams at twitch.tv slash
david pakman
and on august 23rd the 15
year anniversary of the david pakman
show
we will be blowing out a huge membership
special
related to the number 15 because it is
after all our 15-year
anniversary to be notified about that
amazing membership special
make sure to be on our newsletter list
which you can sign up for
at davidpakman.com i will see you on the
bonus show
otherwise tomorrow